we got to talk about one of the most
important people in the world my friends
this is from timcast.com court rules
julian assange can be extradited
overturning previous ruling the final
decision to extradite falls to uk home
security pretty patel
the report says england's high court
said wikileaks founder julian assange
could be extradited to the united states
to face espionage charges and i love how
when you watch the shill establishment
democrat media they're like oh he was
hacking and the case is solid in
mourning joe spewing word vomit about
complete bullish that's not true
here's the reality julian assange is one
of the most important journalists of
this or any generation he exposed
malfeasance for for for i mean his
entire career ranging from malfeasance
in sub-saharan african nations all the
way to the democratic uh national
committee for this the establishment
seeks to destroy his life and they've
locked him up now for what over a decade
how long has it been
um his first arrest was 10 years ago i
believe 10 years no 11 years excuse me
11 years since his arrest in the united
kingdom it is it is overt and in our
faces what the scumbags
who who believe they have moral
authority over you and who control these
systems do with people like julian
assange who has done nothing wrong he's
been accused of of completely bs charges
as far as i'm concerned but let's talk
about something very very important
julian assange exposes corruption
jeffrey epstein was engaged in some of
the most disgusting and psychotic
corruption and atrocities we've seen and
who gets to go free and sit where was he
at queen elizabeth's cottage
yeah oh wow
you know what's really funny is that
they say that there's a conspiracy about
creepy elitists and what they want to do
and all that stuff and it's really funny
when when the maxwell trial ends with
only a few witnesses in a few weeks
epstein gets away with what everything
he's doing for two decades and julian
assange who's like here's here's
evidence of malfeasance they're like
destroy his life and him
it's obvious yeah this is a huge huge
injustice and has major ramifications
for not just free for the free press in
the united states but for the world
julian assange is not an american
citizen for him to be ruled to be
extradited to the united states to face
charges because he embarrassed the deep
state because he embarrassed the
pentagon and the intelligence agencies
of this country by showing the country
what they were actually doing and not
falling for their lives it's just
absolutely insane julian assange
immediately participated
don't bump the camera
suit
we're talking about julian assange
i just heard oh i've been listening
i heard that you were talking about
china
and i was sitting in washington dc and
i've said i've got to go
i've got to go and now i'm here now i'm
here good tell us about it here i am so
hong kong when you were talking about
hong kong and and and thank you so much
for being here libby we we love libby so
we all love libya
it's been a minute it has been a minute
no when when we did not support
hong kong when we passed them over when
we said even going back into the 1990s
remember this was the original
sense of it right
they said if we turn hong kong over
then hong kong's
and liberal system will be passed on and
these ideals of freedom will be go we'll
go into china china will become
democratic the ccp will disintegrate
it'll be amazing and
uh gordon chang wrote his book the
collapse of the ccp and it's it's coming
it's gonna be so great
and you look at everything everything
that luke talks about everything that
tim talks about everyone talks about
yeah we did open up that
that pathway but it wasn't a one-way
street it turned out it was a two-way
street and so we tried to send freedom
in it didn't take but what did they send
our way communism communism
authoritarianism
and we didn't support and i just i had
to come in and say it i just i'm sorry i
had to just come in and say it i've been
sitting outside all day actually oh
really yes i have yeah did you meet my
son downstairs no it's on last year i
know but is he downstairs no no i didn't
see him at all
there was some guy running and screaming
about some chickens earlier i don't know
and the way i don't know if you heard
this last part i was just talking about
sanchez yeah i saw that i said well i
thought that he might be extradited yeah
oh it might okay
i thought it was ruled that so the
appeal was ruled on but there's still
one last uh decision i believe at a
secretarial level um on whether or not
he'll be brought back to the united
states for the crime of embarrassing the
regime
yeah pretty much yeah like that's that's
what it should be is the democratic
justice of american goodness like this
this veneer this like illusion and then
what's really happening is the most
corrupt epstein like child trafficking
thing and it's this is our government is
it's that and so that's why they're
going well the only question you have to
ask about galen maxwell is why was it
that why is it the oldest prosecutor
that sdny assigned to that case is 37
years old the other person they add oh
you got the chart the other person they
add on is james comey's daughter right
then that's not an investigation that's
a cover-up they're sitting there these
are the worst this is the worst
prosecution i've seen you know that she
actually might get acquitted she
actually might get acquitted because
they're not introducing evidence of
specific crimes that she committed in
terms of sex trafficking look i set
through the manafort trial i remember
here are the documents here are the bank
records here are the transfers here are
the emails right i know what it looks
like look look at here this is all you
have to do this is all you have to say
put take the two stories
look at how the government's going after
julian assange and look at how light
they are against elaine maxwell that's
exactly that's exactly what i was saying
and not only that but they have
thousands of photos thousands of video
tapes should have been entered into
evidence twenty thousand yep i gotta
pull up this meme um so i initially
discovered this thanks to sheamus of
freedom tunes because he made a very
hilarious video about left-wing memes
and he talked about this but there was
something i discovered that was really
funny so this woman this is abby
richards and um which she she's a miss
and disinformation researcher this is
fantastic so she has this tweet where
she said conspiracy theories are
everywhere and people don't understand
how harmful they are i made the
conspiracy chart over a year ago here's
the updated version and so it's actually
quite silly she says speculation line
clear here's one that says like grounded
in reality and it's like watergate
mkultra then it says we have some
questions and iran contra is in there
and a lot of people are like we don't
have like we know that happened
that's a historical event yeah it was an
actual government conspiracy here's
here's the thing here's the best part
though right i want to show you this
remember ollie north testifying so let
me let me this is the the old uh um the
old version she made last year i was
gonna say do you have the one from last
year i have the one from last year
there's a reason she had to update right
right but let me just show you i want to
show you i wonder what that is a few
things well hold on let me we'll go
through all of it speaking of china but
let me show you let me show you the most
my favorite one is this
the the top of the pyramid it says world
ruled by supreme shadow elites once you
believe one you usually believe most get
help she calls all of these these
theories anti-semitic and i noticed one
funny one in there when i was reading
this and it says bill gates
microchipping and that is in the
detached from reality anti-semitic
section she had to change it because
apparently she discovered how to use
google
bill gates funds birth control microchip
that lasts 16 years inside the body and
can be turned on or off with remote
control
that's not a conspiracy theory there was
one real there was another one that she
had last year this is the one from this
year right look cultural marxism is up
there yeah of course yeah yeah so the
one right now scroll but go back into
science denial this is the one from last
year zoom in right below where it says
5g look what it says was a conspiracy
theory 19 made in lab i love that one
funny how that one had to get taken off
this year i wonder what could have
happened could it have been soy boys
is not a conspiracy they're a fact dude
i like that alien abductions is less of
a conspiracy theory than and hypogona
it's called
it's called hypogonadism they went after
tucker carlson for talking about this
the idea that with some people when they
can track covet 19 you can go to the
nih's website and see it's called
hypogonadism and it actually will lower
your testosterone the same way that
we've seen testosterone levels going
down since the 1970s yeah what is what
is mattress firm like yeah what is that
so the mattress firm one i know this one
was that the reason that it was the
theory that there were that there
because it was trending onto this is
what i do i find out something is
trending on twitter i say oh this is
trending on twitter and this is what
people are saying and then people say
i'm promoting it right
right so the mattress firm thing was
people said why are there so many
mattress firms how could there possibly
be so many people out there buying a
product that you really only buy once or
twice every you know like in your
lifetime right you buy a mattress um and
so they were i mean think of it how many
times do you buy mattresses you know
what i mean yeah yeah and um
and so the idea is the idea right so the
idea was that it was actually a money
laundering operation and then people
were trying to like
find out if there were some issues going
on because they were going around
yeah i think i know okay so i think yeah
you know so remember they were talking
about the wayfarer thing or the
overstock.com thing and they're like
well this one yeah no that was separate
that was different from yes you guys you
guys ready yeah so in the old conspiracy
chart at the at the very top you see
deep state is up there right and that
one's silly because that just refers to
the the establishment you know
intelligence bureaus which isn't even i
mean it's not a conspiracy it's
literally just a function it's called
the administrative state but just to the
right yeah i used to work there is
celebs moisturize with children's
foreskin
i would like to pull up people i would
like to pull up the guardian from 2018.
i tried the foreskin facial treatment so
you don't have to yeah wow and he
literally says in the guardian they do
this he doesn't look good he looks worse
i think he gets much worse
well there's celebrities bragging about
this uh on national television there was
a number of them saying this on record
yeah nobody there was also there were
all of the silicon valley executives who
were getting the blood of younger people
pumped into them that's true that's been
that's that was true too yeah yeah but
for a while they said it was a
conspiracy it was like it works but the
other thing about about the the mattress
is real quick before no it literally
yeah it is proven that um doing a
transfusion of younger blood helps
regenerate and heal your body is it like
a stem cell thing is that the idea i i
think it's just because there's
something in the blood i forget what
it's called do you know what it's called
i don't know oxygen
your body produces less of some
particular like enzyme or something no
no no no that's the plasma right there's
something else i forgot you have to spin
the blood a little bit and get the right
particles and then um people use it for
like dental surgeries as well yeah
younger people have more of it so they
transfuse younger blood into an older
person it helps regenerate organs and
stuff like that right now but real quick
before we forget the other thing about
the mattresses is that if you want to
upgrade your mattress you can
you don't have to support the money
laundering operation of mattress firm
you use promo code post so the two-inch
or the three-inch topper particularly we
like the bigger one we've got the film
it's amazing i just want to say i
appreciate how unapologetic you are
about it i appreciate the fact that you
are so no one thing that libby does not
everybody knows this she likes to pass
on
the bible stories to her children
to the church
but children in general and one of the
best ways to do that is with the my
pillow
bible story pillow
you pass the pillow cases you pass it's
noah's ark the nativity scene every
single night jack jack says good good
night joseph good night mary good night
baby jesus and good night sheep
available lindell should have you do a
commercial
he really should yeah but his
commercials are next level though his
commercials are next level i could never
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time